[Music]
[Applause]
Albert Breer is the Monday Morning
Quarterback joining us on the program
let me start with Bill
bellich Bill bellich coaching his last
game as Patriots head coach this
weekend I think so um now you know like
you never know what could happen um uh
when when you when craft gets into a
room with bich next week um but I don't
think this is a decision that you wake
up on Monday morning and make in other
words like in some cases an owner will
decide on the last Sunday of the season
I want to sleep on it and it's truly a
Black Monday decision obviously with
something like this there's a lot more
thought that goes into it and it's a
decision that Craft's going to made over
months not weeks and so like that part
of it I think um makes it is going to
make it more difficult for Bill to move
craft off his spot if that's what he
intends to do and um you the very least
I think you know what we've seen over
the last four weeks the team is still
playing hard for Bill and that bill can
still coach but those were never the
issues the issues are systemic here and
I think if Bill were going to stay and
then as the head coach it would come
with a lot of change around him and you
know after losing the most games at any
point 30 years of ownership I'm not sure
crafted even be willing to do that we'll
see and we were wondering are they going
to use that top five top three draft
pick on a quarterback if if they're
sitting there at three or two are they
taking a
quarterback it's hard to say because we
don't know who's making the decision
right now right like I think we make the
ass the Assumption DP that there's going
to be some changes in Personnel um and I
think in all likelihood um you know
Robert Kraft's probably going to want to
hire a general manager now whether
that's somebody internal external but
you know even if Bill stays you know I
would think that maybe you'd want to
empower somebody in scouting based on
where the roster is right now and we
don't know who that person's going to be
right now and we don't know who the
coach is going to be you know that said
I think it's almost I think it's very
difficult to see a scenario
where whether it's Bill bich as the head
coach of gerod mayo is the head coach M
Jones is back in 2024 which puts them in
play for a quarterback next year now if
they were to blow the whole thing up and
go outside the organization and bring in
somebody new from the Shanahan tree or
something like that they maybe ma Jones
would have a chance but if it's either
belich or Mayo I have a hard time seeing
Mack being back here in
2024 and that would put them in the
market for a quarterback um in the draft
now whether or not they're drafting
third or fifth or seventh we don't know
whether or not they're going to like the
guy who's there for them at third or
fifth or seventh we don't know whether
that's a penx or a McCarthy or a Nicks
or whoever it is we don't know what
they're going to think of those people
but they certainly will be in play um
you know I think regardless of who's the
coach um you know whether it's belich
Oro in 2024 give me the reason why the
biggest reason why Jim Harbaugh will go
to the NFL if that's the case the reason
biggest reason will be what unfinished
business in the pros um I think would be
the number one thing and I think close
behind it would be like all the
circumstances with the NCAA you know and
the fact that that thing's not over I
mean when that notice of allegations was
served to him a lot of people conflated
that as like being for everything it
wasn't you know it was just for the the
quote unquote cheeseburger thing which
was really more of like a covid
recruiting violations thing um you know
and and and and so that means the NCA
hasn't even gotten to the notice on the
Conor stallion situation so I wouldn't
blame Jim if he threw his hands up and
says you know what like I've
accomplished what I wanted to accomplish
and like I it's time to move on and I I
think part of his thinking here to is
you know like that the opportunity to go
to the NFL hasn't been vast for him over
the last two years so he knows these
things can be fickle and as great as his
record was in the N at the NFL level
teams weren't falling over themselves
after the 21 season after the 22 season
to go and get him otherwise I think he
might be in the pros right now and so if
there is a strong pursuit of him from
the Chargers from the Raiders um then I
think that's certainly something that he
looks at at 60 years old says time to go
take care of unfinished business in the
leite he's the Monday Morning
Quarterback Albert Breer uh speaking of
the Raiders Antonio Pierce has done a
really good job players seem to like him
but if I guess does Mark Davis hold off
on giving him the official announcement
the title of head coach until he knows
that maybe he doesn't get Jim Harbaugh
could it could it hinge on that yeah
well the number one thing I think we
have to remember here is that he can't
just give him the head coaching job
because of the rules like so so they
have to go through a process and you
know satisfy the Rooney Rule and all the
rest of that right like so they can't in
this day and age you can't do that um I
do think he likes Antonio Pierce I know
like the guys that he counsels with and
there are three players in particular
that he's really counseled with a lot um
you know ahead of the Josh McDaniels and
Dave Ziggler firings and then you know
into all of this and that's Josh Jacobs
Max Crosby and Devonte Adams I think all
three of those guys are strong
proponents of Antonio Pierce but what I
pretty consistently heard over the last
couple of weeks Dan is that he's got a
big swing in him and I don't know
whether that swing is going to be Jim
Harbaugh or Bill belich but I have heard
that he's got a big swing in him and if
he misses if he fails to connect on that
big swing then maybe he turns back to
Antonio Pierce but his dad had a great
relationship with delich I'm sure you
know about that and he's got a
relationship with Jim Harbaugh he tried
to hire him in 2015 when Harbaugh went
to Michigan so one way or the other you
know there's at least a lot of Buzz out
there that that that that Mark's got a
big swing in him and he's going to take
that swing before you know deciding
whether or not to make Antonio Pierce is
his his next head coach I'm sure the
commissioner has a list of things that
if you do X then it cost you y or your
punishment is going to be this but when
it comes to an owner and David teer I
don't know if is there a negotiation
that goes on between the commissioner
and the owner like well David teer do
you think that this was a
negotiation or just I'm finding you
$300,000 and that's it who's whose boss
I that'll answer well that's why I'm
wondering is is it is it a negotiation
between owner and the commissioner I
mean we know who's who's who the boss in
this scenario is so I yeah I mean I
think that there's definitely back and
forth um yeah I I don't know in
specifically in this situation but I do
know in situations like this in the past
you know whether they involved Jerry
Jones or um or or Robert crafter Daniel
Snider's like the primary one right
where they certainly didn't just come
down and and sanction Daniel Snyder
there was back and forth there um Jim
her another one like you know I I think
this would be one of those where there's
definitely some back and forth and I
think you know like to me like the crazy
thing about it Dan is like you couldn't
even take him off out of out of the
stadium this Sunday right like you
couldn't even do that you couldn't even
give him the suspension to take him out
of the stadium this Sunday and why
couldn't you do that well I I'd assume
it's because teer leaned on him right
like the Optics ofer being back in a
stadium this weekend think about that
like I think that's the one piece of
this everybody's missing forget about
the money like the guy's got money
coming out of his ears so whatever the
money is is the money but you know like
I think you know one thing that I can
remember somebody saying to me a long
time ago you know when it came to cover
in the league is like like the one thing
you don't do is you you you don't want
to embarrass a billionaire right and
that's the one thing that really gets
these guys and like I I think in a
certain way if you look at the apology
it wasn't really an apology right has
David teer really skipped embarrassment
here yes and that's why I said you want
to hurt him don't let him go to his
Stadium to watch his team right and like
I that looks to me like that's the part
that looks incredibly weak right because
I mean you could find him $2 million
that's still like a rounding air right
for him I mean like like I I you know
what if you want to if you if you want
to make him feel it you make the story
David teer is not in the stadium today
yeah and then people are looking down
the field they see an interim coach and
they do the they do the math and you
know what the math will show them Dan
that's his this is going to be his 99th
game as the team owner 22 of those 92
games have been presided over by an
interim coach think about that 22 of 99
okay how attractive is this job well
it's one of
32 so that should answer your question
well David terer is one of 32 but he's
not like the other owners he's gonna be
able to find somebody um but like yeah I
mean I think for guys with options like
look at Arizona last year right so
Arizona wasn't a very attractive job you
got a quarterback who maybe you're not
sure on who's got a massive contract
that you're tied to because the
guarantees in it the roster isn't in
really good isn't in very good shape the
owner got some checkered history there
too uh Arizona wasn't a very attractive
job Jonathan Ganon had to take that job
and he's done a great job right like but
he had to take why well because he's a
defensive coach and every year maybe
half the owners decide ahead of time I'm
not hiring a defensive coach right and
then the other half are just going to
consider it's not like those guys have
decided they will so there's going to be
somebody to take the job but if you're
Ben Johnson do you take it that's I mean
that the question probably so I like I
you might not if you have options right
so I think like these things are a
function of a guy's options like is a
guy does a guy have a strong enough
resume where he can wait for a year
right like Dan Quinn's waited a year
twice does a guy have a strong enough
resume where he can wait for a year and
be assured that his stock is still going
to be in good shape a year from now does
a guy have multiple options so he can
look at it and say because I think like
if you look at like whatever the list is
of the the coaching jobs the Panthers
because of the ownership situation are
at the very bottom of it this is like
what Bill parcels and Bill bellich tell
all their assistants would tell all
their assistance right which is there's
one thing that you cannot change no
matter what you do and that's the owner
that's the one thing like no matter what
like remember that when you go and
interview for this job belich and
Parcels would tell their assistants that
like like the one thing you cannot
change is the owner and right now David
teer I mean and it's not just this like
incident in a vacuum this incident
confirmed what everybody thinks about
him already you know like in a three-
second video like everything that's been
rumored everything that's been you know
everything that's been sort of
stereotyped whatever about David terer
like he confirmed all of it in a 3
second video so you know I I just I look
at this and um it's just a really it's
again like I think the Carolina job as
far as desirability will be at the
bottom of the list which means they're
probably going to have to H hire a guy
who doesn't have the leverage to wait
for another year and doesn't have
multiple options good to talk to you as
always Albert thanks for joining us all
right thanks Dan that's Albert Breer
Monday Morning Quarterback always makes
us smarter